they're trying to reach some sort of
resolution in pittsburgh with antonio
brown and the steelers last tuesday out
of the blue he said farewell to
pittsburgh and then over the weekend he
decided he was going to answer questions
on twitter chris he's been promising a
big interview for weeks now he's allowed
both mike tomlin and art rooney the
coach and the owner respectively of the
steelers to speak their piece and not
respond now he decides to go to twitter
i think he's getting very antsy i think
he's getting a little emotional i think
he wants out the fact that they're not
making it clear to him that there's a
path out i think this is this is ticking
toward a potential boom between the
steelers and antonio brown yeah it
certainly seems that way and you know
it's interesting too because you know as
you watch this the whole thing unfold i
think a lot of people and i don't even
know where you stand with this i haven't
even talked to you about this yet but i
think a lot of people think antonio
brown's got all the power in this
situation and i i just had a few
conversations and just you know casual
settings where i just go you know i
don't know about that antonio brown's
got to be careful here first of all the
the the pittsburgh steelers are on the
hook for
20 million dollars or is it 19 million
dollars to be exact of dead money no
matter what whether they trade them keep
them sit them on the bench whatever so
in pittsburgh's situation here they're
kind of getting screwed over no matter
what they can sit back here and play
this as slow as they want for people to
think that they're that they can't drive
a hard bargain with teams who might want
to trade to get antonio brown they're
just incorrect they could they can
basically sit here and go we'll wait all
day and we're going to wait till we get
the compensation we feel we deserve for
antonio brown well
here's where it stands if they trade him
or cut him they will take a cap charge
of 21.1 million dollars but they won't
pay him anything if he's on the team his
cap number is 22 million and they will
pay him about 13 million about 15
million actually for 2019 and the key
date is march 17 that's when a two and a
half million dollar payment becomes due
but the steelers can and i think that if
he keeps pushing them there's a chance
they will eventually say hey antonio we
paid you 19 million dollars to sign two
years ago we paid you over 13 million
dollars in salary the last two years and
bonuses you've got over 32 33 million
dollars in the last two years and we
have you under contract for three more
seasons and you either play for us you
play for no one and and if you play for
us we expect you to show up on time and
if you don't show up on time we are
going to take advantage of all rights we
have under the cba because at some point
chris yes the steelers need to think
about how other players are going to
view how this unfolds 100 mike if if you
set a precedent that you can just talk
your way out of town then anybody can
talk his way out of town yes that a
hundred percent you're right i mean the
pittsburgh steelers they got to be
careful here of of future mutiny really
basically is what they got to protect
against i mean yeah right now the
example that's being shown by antonio
brown is that i can ditch the team and
act unprofessional and not answer the
calls of the head coach or players on
the team or the owner of the team and
then not and then show up and and be off
the radar all week at practice then show
up on sunday expect to
expect to play get told i can't play and
now i'm going to hold a temper tantrum
and say i want out of town because i
feel disrespected no there's a long
history and a long
line of things that he has done wrong uh
and bit and been unprofessional whether
that's late for meetings or all the
other things that we've talked about
through the years and if i am pittsburgh
i'm gonna sit here and go no i'm not
doing anything with you antonio brown
until we find a team that sends us a
first round pick or something like that
because we're losing a ton of money that
we've already invested in you and we
gave you a longer leash than we probably
should have uh to begin with and now
we're stuck in this situation because of
that we're not going to let you just
yell and scream and get your way out of
town
he's banking on the steelers wanting to
turn the page on the drama and the
dysfunction and what he's doing is he's
trying to add to it he took to twitter
on saturday and he offered to answer 10
questions and the first answer was the
most telling he was asked about the
source of his conflict with quarterback
ben rothsberger and he said there's no
conflict just a matter of respect mutual
respect he has an owner mentality like
he can call out anybody including
coaches players know they can't say
anything about it otherwise their meal
ticket is gone it's a dirty game within
a game so yeah he's talking about
the lack of respect that ben
roethlisberger has for the other players
the fact that he feels like he's an
owner and can say what he wants to say
and he's just trying to stir this up and
he's trying to make this conflict
between him and rothersburg to the point
where rothersberger says look it's him
or it's me i don't want the guy here and
there was an interesting
twist that happened on friday afternoon
chris somebody pointed out to me that
antonio brown on his likes and twitter
where you can click that little heart
and you can like a tweet he had liked a
couple of tweets that referred to
roethlisberger's sexual assault
allegations from years ago and there
they were prominent at the top of
antonio brown's likes now he since has
unliked one of them but the message is
clear he's trying to stir it up as best
he can to give the steelers no choice
but to say we can't have this guy around
it's too much drama it's too much
dysfunction we're never going to be
anywhere close to where we want to be as
a team in 2019 if this guy's around
because he's going to make mess after
mess after mess and he's not going to
give up and and this is
t.o in 2005 if social media existed in
2005 because this is what owens would
have done to get out of philadelphia
instead all he could do was shirtless
driveway sit-ups and and be
passive-aggressive or aggressive
aggressive in meetings and and at the
team facility until they finally gave up
on him but now
brown's got this extra weapon in his
arsenal that t.o didn't have and he's
fully and completely using it yeah you
know he definitely is and he and again i
know you and i have talked about this
he's got to be careful a little bit
because if he if he continues to just
throw you know you know gasoline on this
fire with big ben and the pittsburgh
shielders it's going to scare other
teams and other coaches away if it gets
out of hand that's the the first thing
he's got to worry about second thing is
you know listen he he can try to
alienate his whole relationship with big
ben or that i don't think big ben cares
you know that's the other thing like i
don't think he big ben does not seem
like the kind of guy you know first of
all i don't condone any of big ben's
actions and how he calls out players not
cool not the way a leader does it you
don't see the tom brady's or the peyton
mannings or the aaron rodgers do it
quite to that fashion uh the way big ben
did this year that was wrong but at the
same time antonio's gotta be a little
careful because big ben's just the type
of guy that doesn't care if people on
the team like him or not i don't think
big ben really cares if anybody on the
planet likes him maybe other than his
wife and his kids and you know his mom
and his dad he's just not that type of
guy i don't know if you've ever been
around him but he just doesn't give you
the most warm cozy feeling in the world
it doesn't matter if you're a player or
a coach or whatever it is but again i
think antonio brown is powerless in this
situation pittsburgh steelers got to
draw a line in the sand don't let him
dictate how this whole thing goes and
they are on the hook for a lot of money
no matter what so they can sit back and
go here antonio either we get the trade
we want uh you come back and play for us
or you sit there on the sidelines and
just you don't do anything and you
collect no money this year at a very
pivotal part in your career where you're
going to be 31 years old and the slope
is definitely declining or going
downwards
and and chris it's even more aggressive
than that they have paid him 19 million
dollars that's spread out over five
years he would owe them 11.4 million if
he just chooses not to pay yeah a play
rather
and i i don't know that he fully
understands that he appreciates that but
that's part of the conversation i think
art rooney may want to have with him it
was funny last week the news came out
that art rooney ii going to florida
wants to meet with brown initially brown
wasn't going to meet with him then all
of a sudden brown is going to meet with
him look you can disrespect ben
roethlisberger all you want you start
disrespecting the guy who signs the
checks that's right you have a huge huge
problem because then that's when the guy
will start doing things against the
interests of his team
all for the sake of putting a giant
middle finger in your face because we
can't have this as owners of nfl teams
having the players tell us how it's
going to be they've been dealing with
le'veon bell the last two years telling
them how it's going to be this is a bad
bad president for the steelers to set so
i think antonio brown is getting closer
and closer to hearing in no uncertain
terms you got two choices antonio you
play for us or you play for no one if
you play for no one you can start paying
us back that 11.4 million dollars are we
on the same page yeah even if we aren't
this is how it's going to be yeah it
seems like it could go that way uh it
definitely does i just wonder what the
compensation they're looking for that
would justify him and justify trading
him and getting him out the door you
know i mean obviously a first round pick
i think that would get it done but are
they to the point where you know if it's
a high second round pick something like
that are they gonna are they gonna flirt
with that to just you know kind of fold
fold the cards and say we're out of the
antonio brown business i wonder what the
price will be to finally make the move
or at least have the deep conversation
about trading antonio brown chris
whatever it is they're not there yet no
because we know we're in that we're in
that window where we we can find out
right that there's a deal in place for a
player that becomes official on march
13. we found that out last week when joe
flacco tentatively was traded from the
ravens of the broncos so if somebody had
given the steelers enough that they
would say yes it would already be done
even though it can't officially be done
yeah until the middle of march
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports